so uh we learned from a new abc news
ipsos poll
that donald trump's favorability has
actually declined
since the republican convention by a
little bit now
to understand why this is important and
then what the limits are
we should first talk a little bit about
what normally happens when there are
conventions so if you if you go back
many decades
the way that it typically works is the
incumbent
party has their convention second
but regardless you see that whoever has
their convention first
gets a little bit of a bump in the
polling and favorability
and then the numbers settle back down
and then whoever goes second with their
convention gets a little bump in the
polling and favorability and then it
comes back down
and by the time we get into september
and debates and then october
and all of the things that happen in the
two months leading up to an election
the effect of the conventions is
essentially sort of zeroed out things
returned to the mean
that's the normal situation according to
a new poll from abc news and ipsos
donald trump has not even gotten the
bump in favorability donald trump
now has 31 favorability
in the united states and he went into
the republican national convention with
32 percent favorability now what's
really important to remember about that
is that there are many people who have
an unfavorable view of trump
and are still going to vote for him much
like there are people
who have an unfavorable view of joe
biden but are going to vote for him
because they
accurately recognize that he's a better
choice than donald trump so
even though trump's favorability is in
the low 30s
donald trump is certainly going to get
40-something percent of the popular vote
in november and exactly where
in the 40s he falls is going to
determine whether he gets re-elected or
not
if we look at the internals of this
favorability decline
trump's favorability during the
convention or
since the convention dropped four points
among republicans so republicans were
were
particularly not thrilled with what they
saw
during the convention on individual
issues
coronavirus continues to be a big
problem for trump
where 63 percent of americans disapprove
of his handling uh and then just for
comparison joe biden's favorability went
up
six points from pre to post convention
40 to 46 now it's still not great and
this is one of the reasons why
if you want to compare this election to
one
from times past you look at 2016 where
you had two candidates
in 2016 it was hillary clinton and
donald trump in 2020 you have joe biden
and donald trump
neither of whom has 50 favorability now
the difference between biden at 46 and
trump at 31
is significant but of course it's
ultimately going to come down
to a handful you know five to eight or
so
uh battleground states and we're going
to talk about that in a little bit now
in terms of who watched the convention
we talked last week in the week before
during the convention coverage
about who is this really for
we learned that 72 percent
watched very little or none of the
conventions
so it continues to be clear that voters
who watched a lot
of the conventions over the last couple
of weeks are voters who
are already definitely voting in other
words they were definitely voting even
before the conventions
started they weren't convinced to vote
by the conventions and number two
are almost certainly already decided and
that is an important thing to think
about in terms
of the reviews of the conventions when
donald trump brags that his speech was
very well reviewed
or someone else says trump's speech was
bad or biden was good or whatever the
case may be
um most people who watch these
conventions
are already very much decided and a lot
of people are simply not watching them
at all so what really matters is for us
to step back and look at the trends
if you look at one trend like the gallup
presidential approval tracking poll
interesting there that donald trump has
never
hit 50 percent approval on even
one sampling of the gallup presidential
approval
tracking poll during his entire
presidency donald trump never
hit 50 percent but half the country does
not vote which means that
even without 50 approval even without
35 percent favorability donald trump
can still win in action not voting
is an action it has an effect and it has
never never been more dangerous than it
is right now
in many swing states donald trump is
doing okay shockingly if you're paying
attention to what's going on
you should be shocked by this in many
swing states
donald trump's approval on coronavirus
has actually started to tick up
even if it's still one of the biggest
areas of liability for donald trump
nationally so when we talk about
if trump wins what will it mean yeah it
will mean that there are lots of
easily uh manipulable people in the
country
it will mean that there are lots of
cognitively compromised people
but democrats are going to have some
responsibility to bear i mean if
democrats lose this
with trump at 31 approval you can't just
blame
trumpists for being dumb that would be a
complete lack of self-awareness it would
partially be the inability to control
the narrative against donald trump
the inability to actually put together
uh
it doesn't even have to be perfect
messaging just good enough messaging to
beat someone whose
31 favorability rating is historically
low
get out the vote will have been a
failing for sure because we know that
non-voters from 2016 overwhelmingly
favor joe biden
if you can't get them to vote you're
going to have some responsibility to
bear as well
so there are lots of elements of this
feeling like 2016
and when you look at these numbers when
you look at the polling data i looked at
with you last week
the last thing any of us should be doing
is thinking joe biden's got this in the
bag it's not reverse gas lighting
it's not concerned trolling it's looking
a lot like 2016
in many ways hopefully it ends up
differently let me know what you think
i'm on
twitter at dpakman one of our sponsors
today is
surf shark a premium vpn service
packed with a ton of useful features
giving my audience
85 off a two-year plan
this is under two bucks a month plus
you'll get three
extra months for free it's 20 20. if
you're not using a vpn you should really
start
online government surveillance is a
problem internet providers can
sell your internet history big tech
companies
track what you do online you can protect
yourself against all of this
just by using a vpn and the one i use is
surf
shark because it comes with all kinds of
special features it's a company
you can trust with your online privacy
surfshark
hides your ip address removes ads
protects you from
malware and phishing attempts and it
allows you to stream content
that's only available in other countries
you can install surfshark on
unlimited devices and surfshark never
monitors or logs
your internet activity surfshark is
giving my audience 85
off a two-year plan which comes out to
less than two bucks a month
plus you'll get three extra months for
free
go to surfshark.deals
pacman the link is right underneath this
video